如果对方不赌不平衡，
不在外面欠债，
没有任何不良嗜好，
人家也挣钱，
人家也对家庭有责任心的话，
那么你就要改变你对待他的方式。
我其实有一个非常好用的心法，
这个心法是什么？
把他当儿子看，
把他当儿子一样对待，
把他当儿子一样哄，
特别好用。
你儿子拉屎拉的好，
你都得夸一下，
你儿子爬楼梯爬的好，
没摔着，
你都得夸一下，
不管是儿子还是女儿吧，
你把他当儿子一样哄，
这关系好处的很。
我昨天跟我老公吵架，
然后就提了分手嘛，
我们结婚有4年了，
这孩子3岁多，
上幼儿园，
但是这4年的话，
结婚就是我没有工作，
就是等于全职，
在我我们结婚之前，
他父母付了首付给他买了房，
小孩子1岁多的时候，
就我们向我的父母借了20万，
他父母也借了20多万，
我提前还了这个房贷，
现在因为提分手这件事嘛，
我要求他给他把我父母这20万还了，
但后我提供的两万块钱，
总共就是22万，
他把这个还了我才同意，
如果他去还的话，
我不同意，
我想要那个小孩子的抚养权嘛，
小孩子呢，
想上幼儿园，
他爸爸是不同意的，
我要求是3000，
他说2500，
我今前讲了一下，
我也同意了，
但是他爸爸现在反悔了，
然后就是他要抚养权，
这是两点，
第三点呢，
我跟他提的要求是我结婚四年没有工作，
要求经济补偿，
我按的是。
这边正常保姆的话，
就是全职保姆的话，
一个月我知道可能有五千六千的嘛，
但是实际上拿不到那么多，
我就按一年3万，
四年12万去要求他的，
我知道可能拿不到这么多，
但是我是提的这些要求，
那你现在就是他不愿意出这个经济补偿，
只愿意还我爸妈的20万和我的2万，
给孩子他的抚债钱，
他也要争第一还你爸妈那个20万的话，
我感觉抓紧时间得打个欠条，
让你爸妈出面，
让你们两口子打欠条，
别到时候越拖到后面的话，
就20万越悬，
现在趁着还没离呢，
还没撕破脸呢，
赶紧让你爸妈出面，
就是你俩在家的时候，
你爸妈上来把欠条打好了，
上来让你俩签字，
他就嫁在那儿了，
他也只能签字呀，
赶紧办这个事儿啊，
这是大头，
第二个因为你是全职在家带娃，
你在分开的时候要求一个家务补偿，
这确实是有这样一个权利在，
但是家务补偿的话，
可能一年也就几千块钱，
就目前来看，
我知道我觉得就是我这四年的付出，
就彩礼啊什么的，
包括一些我爸妈给我的一些经济方面的东西啊，
我全部都那前期因为是他还房贷嘛，
就经济方面不是特别好，
前一两年就是小孩子所有的基本上开销都是我在出，
他只提供一个就是基础的，
每个月3000块钱，
包括一家三口的那个生活费，
你像小孩子额外的一些费用啊什么的基。
然上都是我在承担，
但是这个的话，
因为时间也久，
可能也没有那个记录，
有记录也没有用，
因为两口子过日子啊，
不管谁付的钱多，
谁付的钱少，
付出去的钱是回不来的，
付出去的钱是不能拿离婚的时候再来分割的，
花了就是花了，
要分只能分剩下的是这个意思，
就是谁花的钱多，
这事儿真到我俩要分开的时候，
人家法院是不管的，
我知道这个经济补偿有点难，
但是我就不甘心，
因为我爸妈借了20万给他，
他一生气，
一吵架，
然后就直接喊我，
直接让我滚，
说一句不好听话，
这是我不甘心，
我觉得我父母因为我借了你20万，
让你提前20年把你的那个房贷还了，
我不要求他分我房产，
也不要求那个啥，
我只望他给济补偿，
拿不到这么多，
我也要求，
因为他不是不同意离婚，
他说他不能满足我的要求，
我说你不满足我的要求的话，
那我这边就是不同意离婚，
姑娘啊，
这样我先帮你捋一遍，
你能争取的是什么，
能谈判的条件是什么，
我们再往下聊好不好？
第一，
你们领完结婚证之后，
所有的还款部分，
不管这个钱来自于哪里，
但从法律来讲的话，
还房贷的还款部分，
以及相应的增值涨价部分，
你都可以要求分割，
明白吗？
你别上来就说我不要，
上来就说咱合法分，
这样你。
有谈判的筹码和基础在，
你作为全职的妈妈确实可以要求家务补偿，
这个也是法律规定的非常明确的，
就是一方在家庭贡献养育子女，
照顾老人这些付出的，
补助对方工作付出的更多的，
这一方确实是可以要求一个补偿，
这个补偿不管说一年5000也好，
6000也好，
1万也好，
我可以提要求。
第三，
我可以公平的来分配我们现在家庭的共同存款，
这个共同的存款，
甭管是你工资攒下来的，
你公积金攒下来的，
你被开除了赔偿的，
都是夫妻共同的，
我可以要求分，
这三点是法律明确规定的，
我都可以要求提的，
那我都要啊，
我才能谈判呢，
就这意思。
第4，
你父母给的那20万，
你就按我刚刚说的，
今天晚上就凑个饭局，
让你父母来提前写好这个欠条，
你们两口子签字按手印，
把这个欠条留着，
最起码能保证娘家20万，
这个钱不是肉搏打狗，
有去无回，
明白吧，
问题是他不同意我提的要求，
你打官司该怎么判就怎么判，
他的想法就是起诉状，
他把房子做抵押，
然后抵押的钱就是还给我父母，
然后其他的就都不同意，
按照我说的，
做你父母这个事儿的话，
必须得有欠条啊，
不然到时候又是一团乱麻一股之，
我父母跟他父母现在都不知道，
因为我父母是不知道的，
我去年也因为一些事情也。
是回家就是干过离婚，
但是没办成，
因为我父母不同意，
他父母也不同意，
今天这次的话也是我不晓得他有没有跟他父母说，
但是我现在没有跟我父母说，
因为产生的问题不是大问题，
感觉是两个人的性格观点上面是没办法调和的那种情况，
你跟我说，
说实话你到底想不想离，
80%吧，
因为有小孩，
多少还是要为小孩子考虑一点嘛。
好，
那你想问我的问题是什么，
他就是不同意我的条件，
我不同意离婚，
就是他起诉讼能离吗？
能，
现在的婚姻关系是这样，
只要有意头铁了心的要离，
反正早晚得离，
那他起诉他离婚的话，
我抚养权还能拿到吗？
能不能拿到抚养权这个事儿取决于你能不能向那个裁判者去证明，
孩子跟着你能过得更好，
现在孩子是3岁多了是吧？
你需要举出一切可以找到的证据来证明孩子跟着你能过得更好，
这个2岁到8岁这个区间的话，
就是比比谁能让那个裁判者达成心理确信，
就孩子跟着他肯定能过更好，
孩子跟着他肯定能得到更多的关照陪伴，
孩子跟着他肯定能三观啊，
各方面都培养的挺好，
你必须要有这个证据，
你才有可能争到孩子的培养权，
他有暴力倾向，
但是我没办法证明他有暴力倾。
那就想办法证明，
包括他一些那种抽烟喝酒的毛病都有，
但是这个东西你去看一下，
我大概是在2024年11月份发布的一个系列讲座的视频，
就在抖音账号上就有系统的讲解了。
你想争孩子抚养权，
你要准备哪些证据？
我感觉你得先出去找个工作，
你最起码得证明孩子跟着你不会饿死。
如果我找工作的话，
我就没办法完全带款，
那就得爸妈帮忙了，
我们是在外地，
不太想让父母知道，
那就带着孩子回娘家，
回娘家找份工作，
如果你真的想争取孩子的抚养权的话，
你就得照我说的做，
不然的话你就争不到孩子的抚养权，
可是关键在于我不想让父母担心，
我所以才没有跟父母说这件事，
我理解你，
但是所有的东西都是权衡利弊，
所有的东西都得有一个轻重缓急，
你这头说啊，
我不想让父母担心，
那你就会丧失孩子的抚养权，
我问你哪头重哪头轻，
指的是性格和观念上面的不合，
不是因为说积极啊什么之类的，
就感觉两个人对待一件事的想法是不一样的。
如果对方不不平。
不在外面欠债，
没有任何不良嗜好，
人家也挣钱，
人家也对家庭有责任心的话，
那么你就要改变你对待他的方式。
我其实有一个非趁好用的心法，
这个心法是什么？
他当儿子看，
把他当儿子一样对待，
把他当儿子一样哄，
特别好用。
你儿子拉屎拉的好，
你都得夸一下，
你儿子爬楼梯爬的好，
没摔着，
你都得夸一下，
不管是儿子还是女儿吧，
你把他当儿子一样哄，
这个关系好处的很。
而如果通过小孩的爷爷奶奶去，
千万不要，
我觉得最蠢的事情就是通过外部压力说想要让他对我好一点，
这是最蠢的做法，
最治标不治本，
而且会埋更大的雷。
千万不要，
你去学一下儿童心理学，
你有一天你就想象一下，
如果他是我儿子，
我该怎么对他，
可是他也提供不了给我情绪价值啊，
现在是你不想人家想离，
你还想让人家给你提供情绪价值，
你想啥呢？
我没有不想离，
我只是想要最起码满足我的基本的3个条件，
我觉得我可以离婚，
没有说不想离，
只是我不想离的原因是他不愿意满足我的条件。
你是一把吧，
从今天开始，
把你的老公别当成你的老公看，
就当成你亲儿子，
你去发现他身上的优点，
你去夸他，
你去哄着他，
把他哄成胎盘，
你看一下这日子好不好过，
好不好，
其实就真的很小的问题，
都是因为别人的问题，
他就觉得我对他父母不好，
对他姐妹不好，
就比如说出去玩。
他只给他们多花了一点钱，
他就必须让我跟着，
也必须花多少钱，
那个好像我们就亏欠他的样子，
就是每次都是因为这种小问题争吵，
大问题上面从来都没有过。
还有一个心法，
姐妹啊，
我感觉啊，
我真的是对得起我的客户，
对得起这300块钱啊。
还有一个心法，
你你要是学会的话，
以后日子也超好过，
这个心法你给我一字一句的在脑海里面每天过100遍，
这个心法是什么呢？
这件事情会影响我的身体健康吗？
这件事情会影响我孩子的身体健康吗？
这件事情会让我损失大部分的财产吗？
如果这件事情不会响我的身体健康，
不会影响我孩子的身体健康，
不会让我损失大部分的财产的话，
我就听我老公的，
他说怎么做就怎么做，
他说怎么干就怎么干，
他说给多少就给多少，
这事子老好过了，
特别好过。
现实生活中我就是这么干的，
老公听你的，
老公你说了算，
老公这个家你做主，
只要不影响老娘身体健康，
只要不影响我孩子的身体健康，
只要不影响老娘挣钱，
只要不会对我造成太大的财产损失，
我可乖了，
我可听话了，
我可顺着他了，
特别好用。
我说的这段话价值千金，
每天你在心里面，
你就默念，
就默念，
会影响我身体健康，
会影响我孩子的身体健康吗？
会让我损失我大部分的财产吗？
我都听我老公的，
你要是往心里去的话，
你这日子好过得很，
超好过。
龙飞这几句话各学一。
累死了，
千金买不来是真的，
记得点赞关注哦。